what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to my
reaction series where I read pill women
and today I have a special guest uh
Sophia welcome to the show thank you for
having me so um in this series I was
just telling you before I will show you
content that is very big in our space of
YouTube okay that we would call goaded
the best
um so do you have any idea who this guy
is Jordan Peterson no not clear okay so
a little background Autumn he's a
psychologist okay and he is from Canada
right and he got in trouble a couple
years ago for
um he said that he did not want the
government to force him to use people's
pronouns okay does that make sense yeah
okay so this is an interview um he also
has a book which you know a lot of young
men tend to like watch his stuff so
um women too I watch it but um so you
don't know who Jordan Peterson is what
do you think about women being oppressed
or women oppressed also feel free to
disagree with me at any point you know
I'm very nice what do you mean by that
do you think women are oppressed in
society you think it's harder for women
than men in some ways yes some ways no
okay so she's she's in the middle all
right I'm gonna show you Jordan Peterson
you've said that men need to quote grow
the hell up tell me why well because
there's nothing uglier than an old
infant there's nothing good about it
people who don't grow up don't find this
sort of meaning in their life that
sustains them through difficult times
and they are certain to encounter
difficult times and they're left bitter
and resentful and without purpose and
adrift and hostile and resentful and
vengeful and arrogant and deceitful and
and of no use to themselves and of no
use to anyone else and no partner for a
woman done there's nothing in it that's
good so you said I mean that sounds
pretty bad you're saying there's a
crisis of masculinity I mean what do you
do about it you tell you help people
understand why it's necessary and
important for them to grow up and adopt
responsibility why that isn't uh shake
your finger and get your act together
sort of thing why it's more like why
it's more like a delineation of the kind
of destiny that makes life worth living
I've been telling young men and but it's
not I wasn't specifically aiming this
message at young men to begin with it
just kind of turned out that way and
it's mostly you admit it's mostly men
listening I mean it is then your
audience is amazing well it's about 80
on on YouTube which is a YouTube is a
male domain primarily so it's hard to
tell how much of it is because YouTube
is male and how how much of it is
because of what I'm saying but um you
you what I've been telling young men is
that there's an actual reason why they
need to grow up which is that they have
something to offer you know that that
people have within them this capacity to
set the world straight and that's
necessary to manifest in the world and
what do you think so far first minute of
Jordan Peterson it's hard to say hard to
say yeah okay well we'll watch it keep
on watching them also doing so is where
you find the meaning that sustains you
in life so what's going wrong then oh
God all sorts of things have gone wrong
I I think that I don't think that young
men are hear words of encouragement some
some of them never in their entire lives
as far as I can tell that's what they
tell me and the fact that the words that
I've been that I've been speaking the
YouTube lectures that I've done and put
online for example have had such a
dramatic impact is an indication that
young men are starving for this sort of
message because like why in the world
would they have to derive it from a
lecture on YouTube no they're not being
taught that they that it's important to
develop yourself does it does it bother
you that your audience is predominantly
male does that isn't isn't that a bit
divisive no I don't think so I mean it's
no more divisive than the the fact that
YouTube is primarily male and tumblers
female isn't it tumblr is primarily
female right you're just saying That's
the Way It Is Well it's I'm not saying
anything it's just an observation that
that's the way it is
um there's plenty of women that are
watching my lectures and coming to my
talks and buying my books it's just the
majority of them happen to be men uh
it's what's in it for the women though
well what sort of partner do you want
you want an overgrown child or do you
want someone to contend with that's
going to help you rely on women have
some sort of Duty to sort of help fix
the crisis masculinity it depends on
what they want no I mean it's it's
exactly exactly how I laid it out like
women want deeply want men who are
competent and powerful and and I don't
mean power in in in the in that they can
exert tyrannical control over others
that's not power that's just corruption
power is competence and why in the world
would you not want a competent partner
well I I know why actually you can't
dominate a competent partner what do you
think about that what are you saying I
mean I feel like he's not wrong in a way
okay tell me because for me personally
if a guy doesn't have confidence right
right then it just puts him down more in
like Society for me personally and what
do you think of the woman I don't know
yet you don't know yet okay that's all
right do you think there is a crisis of
masculinity you think that's true uh men
are at math do you do you find that like
young men are masculine anymore some of
them obviously some of them are very
like quite they they're more insight
they're feminine side which I appreciate
like go you but then I don't appreciate
I think it's bad do you why because at
the same way I don't think we should
have men trying to be women I don't
think we should have women trying to be
men no I think we like the world kind of
tells men to be women and I think it's
bad for them in the long run yeah I feel
I get what you're saying but I also feel
like if a guy wants to say like dress
more like feminine like masculine like
Essex type kind of thing right then as a
I feel like go ahead and like dress you
know them as they say like long like
trousers that look Femme and like stuff
yeah I think that's bad I think you I
think men should dress like men and
women should dress like women I think I
think you're free to do what you want
yeah I think it's bad for society when
we're trying to like blur the lines
between gender yeah I think gen like I
think society's better when we're more
different than we are the same as men
and women yeah no I do I do get exactly
what you're saying and agree to an
extent to an extent yeah it's funny
that's what I've noticed like the girls
that aren't too confrontational they'll
say I agree to an extent really yeah
yeah where it's like I kind of agree but
kind of it's okay it's like you're most
yeah but yeah
um so okay so now it's gonna get a
little bit more confrontational if you
want me you should dominate is that what
you're saying no I'd say women who have
had their relationships impaired with
impaired their relationships with men
impaired and who are afraid of such
relationships will settle for a weak
partner because they can dominate them
but it's a sub-optimal solution
do you think that's true like women that
run relationships it's not their first
choice I think if they're wanting to do
that then that's like their choice in a
way do you do you know any women that do
that that they like wear the pants they
run the relationship no no really you
don't know any no but like I would
prefer what about what about like
friends parents no really not why wow
okay maybe one like back in Australia
but like not here yeah that's that's
what I was asking yeah growing up
because when I think of like my friend's
parents where the mom was really
dominant yeah like she just wasn't happy
in the marriage she kind of hated her
husband
oh I feel like there are friends back
home that the mums obviously overpowers
yeah the relationship and now their
parents aren't together yeah yeah that's
that's what I'm doing yeah that's what
he's getting at is like that type of
relationship just doesn't really work no
yeah there's like a 50 50 like oh yeah
she's from Australia yeah we can't tell
the difference between England and
Australia wait what why the accents
sound the same do I can't now because I
live here well no I don't sound
Australian anymore I can put it on
really yeah guys I'm from the Gold Coast
in Australia wait when did you move here
uh 2020 August
it's already gone your accent yeah how
I've been here too long so I've been
here two years
yeah but Americans like yeah very like
loud so what I'm curious what cultural
what cultural differences do you see
from Australia to England oh many
so number one if you're walking on the
street we're going for a run here
compared to Australia in Australia
you'll go and you say hello to everyone
I noticed the same thing nobody says hi
here I did it when I first came me too I
acknowledged them and they're like yeah
I can't do that me too yeah goodbye
that's funny I used to do like on The
Tick Tock I got this account banned but
I would do saying hi to people in London
and I would just videos like hi and then
just to see if anyone would say hi back
yeah and half the time they don't it's
so rude yeah I'm like are you not going
to say thank you or anything a little hi
no no what about in dating what have you
noticed about the Australian men versus
the the British men well I never really
don't eat Australians to be honest just
I will just stick heads really what like
players what do you mean by
yeah okay they why do you think they're
more of players there than England I
mean they're both as bad as each other
really but I don't know there's just a
difference between what I'm not really
like into the British men but it's like
they're all like Spanish Italian kind of
okay but they just live here so you
don't find them as attractive as
Australian men no I say British are
better than those oh British are more
attractive yeah you know why um the men
so when you say like you said
right yeah does that mean like cheaters
players is that your sort of or what do
you mean by it's just more
like they're annoying and like they they
just don't Don't Fit My Vibe kind of
thing okay what does that mean fit your
Vibe
like they're not me like I can't deal
with them okay they're too full on what
do you what do you sorry sometimes I
can't say things and I just don't know
what it means what is like twofold like
if you were telling a guy that one like
this guy you're thinking of maybe or a
couple guys you're thinking of that
maybe wanted to date you or whatever and
you said no like what was the reason
like what did they do well to me that I
didn't do anything but I just I just
wasn't really interested and I couldn't
go there okay okay I still don't really
get why but but I was just wondering
like which men are better and why
they're better or worse so I'll tell you
why I think that British guys are better
looking and better like I'll say I'll
tell you and it's actually because I
think that don't take this this is a
year but I think the women are less
attractive in England so I think you
kind of get a pointer that's great yeah
so it's like you come here and you're
like wow wow and I also the men are are
taller here they're like 30 or over six
foot eight ball yeah yeah they are
because um in in major cities it might
be different but across the board like
15 of men are over six foot but in
London it's like 25 to 30 percent of men
are over six foot so to me that
indicates the men are better looking and
the women are uglier I'm like I fit
right in
it's like it's like um in the U.S they
kind of have a saying like Chicago
versus like Miami girl like I'm from
Chicago yeah yeah yeah it's like the
Midwest girls aren't the prettiest in
Miami yeah so that's what I think
personally the the men are a bit but but
I will say they are a bit more feminist
like feminine here yeah they aren't as
like masculine they're slightly more
masculine in the U.S and this is why all
the time like Sam's going through Tick
Tock yeah this is why I always land on
the Americans page oh because they're
more masculine yeah so you do like
masculine men yeah I do yeah okay well I
just I just wasn't sure based on your
answers yeah yeah but no I do yeah we'll
we'll continue though I think there's a
substantial minority of women who do
that and I think it's very bad for them
they're very unhappy it's very bad for
their Partners although their Partners
get the advantage of not having to take
any responsibility but what gives you
right to say that I mean maybe that's
how women want their relationships those
women I mean you're making these vast
generalizations I'm a clinical
psychologist right so you're saying
you've done your research and women are
unhappy dominating men I didn't say they
were unhappy dominating men I said it
was a bad long-term solution okay you
said it was making them miserable yes it
is it depends on the time frame I mean
there can be there's intense pleasure in
momentary domination that's why people
do it all the time but it's no formula
for a long-term successful long-term
relationship that's reciprocal right any
long-term relationship is reciprocal
virtually by definition so let me put a
quote to you from the book well you see
there are whole disciplines in
universities forthrightly hostile
towards men these are the areas of study
dominated by the postmodern stroke
neo-marx's claim that Western culture in
particular is an oppressive structure
created by white men to dominate and
exclude women but then I want to put
minorities to dominators okay but I want
to put to you that here in the UK for
example let's take that as an example
the gender pay Gap stands at just over
nine percent you've got women at the BBC
recently saying that the broadcaster is
illegally paying them less than men to
do the same job you've got only seven
women running the top ftse 100 companies
so it seems to a lot of women that
they're still being dominated and
excluded to quote your words back to you
it does seem that way but multivariate
analysis of the pay Gap indicate that it
doesn't exist but that's just true is it
I mean that nine percent pager that's a
gap between media in hourly earnings
between men and women yeah but there's
multiple reasons for that one of them is
gender but it's not the only reason like
if you're a social scientist worth worth
your salt you never do a univariate
analysis like you say well women in
aggregate are paid less than men okay
well then we break it down by age we
break it down by occupation we break it
down by interest we break it down by
personality but you're saying basically
it doesn't matter if women aren't
getting to the top because that's what's
skewing that gender pay Gap isn't it
you're saying well that's just a fact
I'm not going to get to the top no I'm
not saying it doesn't matter either
you're saying there are multiple reasons
for it yeah but there is reason why why
should women put up with those reasons
why should women be content I'm not
saying that they should have put up with
it I'm saying that the claim that the
wage gap between men and women is only
due to sex is wrong and it is wrong
there's no doubt about that the
multivariate analysis have been done
I'm saying that nine percent pay Gap
exists that's a gap between men and
women I'm not saying why it exists but
it exists now if you're a woman that
seems pretty unfair you have to say why
it exists but do you agree that it's
unfair if you're a woman not necessarily
and on average you're getting paid nine
percent less what do you think I'm just
shook because it's annoying and I agree
with her in a way saying that like women
should be set paid the same amount as
men regardless of the job what about
what about the amount of work they do so
if women are what if you do a worse job
no no hold on hold on say that again say
that again women yeah should be paid the
same amount as men yeah regardless of
the job how does that make sense because
it's unfair so if I'm working as a
producer here yeah you're the cleaner we
should be paid the same no so if you're
doing the same job so if I was doing
your job you said regardless of the job
yeah so if I was doing your job I should
be paid same as you yeah but you
probably would be paid the same amount
as me yep nine times out of ten we're
lower you get paid less that's not true
what happens is I probably would work
more hours than you yeah man work more
hours I'll tell you this I've I've hired
like men and women women always take
vacation men don't women don't want to
work as hard as men I think it depends
on the woman because personally no
you're right it does depend on the woman
yeah I would say I work harder than a
lot of women yeah however I would say we
can't have conversations if we can't
make generalizations yeah and I would
say in general women take more vacations
they don't want to work as hard and they
don't want to do the hardest jobs so
like who's building a building next door
men yeah
it's interesting interesting because
you're
you know the guy annoying in this right
yeah it's so funny because we I think
the girl's annoying because I think
she's not listening okay you've never
seen it
don't don't feel bad because I don't
expect you to know this stuff but so
she's basically saying like this is this
is the pay Gap don't you think it's
unfair but we have to look at why
there's a pay Gap yeah yeah so is it
unfair if the men work more hours no if
you do the same amount of hours right
but you're still getting paid less an
hour right that's unfair so is it is it
unfair if you didn't ask for more money
so no because you can always ask for
more money correct and that's the other
thing um I think it's 70 of women I've
never asked for a raise yeah so women We
complain that we don't get paid as much
but we a lot of women quit before they
ask for a raise yeah and but you see
that's the thing they keep conflicting
the argument because and I'm not going
at you I'm just pointing at something so
just from what you said you said
um if you are doing the same job yeah we
should get paid the same which is true
and which is actually what happens so on
the base salary have you ever applied
for a job maybe you go on job on
um indeed yeah when you're apply for a
job do you see okay we want to hire a
dancer women's pay nine pounds per hour
men's pay 10 pounds per hour or do you
see we want to hire a Dancer the pay is
10 pounds per hour hey it's this month
so how how are we not been paid the same
but it depends on the job like in in
like in in London on like Financial
things and like that those type of jobs
the men will get paid more because most
of those jobs come with commissions and
hours put in yeah that's that's the only
way a man can get paid more than a woman
in this Western Society because it's
actually illegal for you to pay a man
and a woman two different salaries for
the exact same thing interesting okay
the man that's not fair is it it depends
on why it's happening I can give you an
example okay there's a personality trait
known as agreeableness agreeable people
are compassionate and polite and
agreeable people get like paid less than
just less agreeable people for the same
job women are more agreeable than men
again a vast generalization
that's true but but that's right and
some women get paid more than men so you
were saying that by and large women are
too agreeable to get the pay Rises I'm
saying that that's one component of a
multivariate equation that predicts
um salary it accounts for maybe five
percent of the variance something like
that so surely you need about another 20
you need about another 18 factors one of
which is gender and there is Prejudice
there's no doubt about that but it
accounts for a much smaller proportion
of the variance in the pay Gap than the
radical feminists claim okay so rather
than denying the pay Gap exists which is
what you did at the beginning of this
conversation shouldn't you say to women
rather than being agreeable and not
asking for a pay rise go and ask for a
pay rise make yourself disagreeable with
your boss oh definitely there's that but
I also didn't deny it existed I denied
it it existed because of gender okay
because I'm very very very careful with
my words so the pay Gap exists you
accept that but you're saying I mean the
pay gap between men and women exists
you're saying it's not because of gender
it's because women are too agreeable to
ask for pay Rises one of the reasons
okay one of the reasons so why not get
them to ask for a pay rise
many many times in my career oh they do
it all the time you can it's so one of
the things that you do as a clinical
psychologist is
um assertiveness training so you might
say often you treat people for anxiety
you treat them for depression um and you
and maybe the next most common category
after that would be assertiveness
training and so I've had many many women
extraordinarily competent women in my
clinical and Consulting practice and we
put together strategies for their career
development that involve continual
pushing competing for higher wages and
often tripled their wages within a
five-year period did you celebrate of
course so do you actually do you agree
that you would be happy if that pay Gap
was eliminated completely because that's
all the radicals so you know it's
interesting why do people expect
equality in anything like if you um take
if you look in a fan family right yep
firstborns usually have the highest IQ
and they're usually the smartest so even
in a family it's usually not equal so
it's interesting like why would two
groups of people have equal outcomes in
anything like you could divide two
groups of people based on height like
tall people tend to make more money than
short people is that true
they make up a larger percentage of like
CEOs presidents well I've got no luck do
I
well I mean you're you're very pretty so
you're gonna have I'm sure you've had
opportunity in dancing because you're
beautiful right so yeah yeah I've got
privileges right everybody no everyone
has strengths and weaknesses yeah yeah
even even you getting invited today yeah
yeah I was just like oh okay yeah but
that's what I mean it's like everybody's
got like strengths and weaknesses yeah
so but like why do we assume two groups
are gonna perform the same in anything
I'm not we could even say first children
and youngest children you know the
youngest children I could see why the
youngest children of worse outcomes
usually more spoiled what do you mean
yes agree like in my family so there's
my brother me and my little sister yeah
my brother obviously he was the
firstborn then I came along got ignored
and I was a favorite then my little
sister came along then they would gang
up on me and now I'm just like the
middle child yeah yeah and it probably
makes sense you're an entertainment
right no because middle children tend to
want attention which yeah I'm a middle
child too so it's like yeah
give me the attention please right but
but so it's interesting because a lot of
times like what they do is they they say
that inequality is like some sort of
Injustice and I think that's like not
very honest by like a lot of
intellectuals like they'll make it seem
like women were not paid the same as men
that's not fair when a lot of times it's
really fair it's just we don't do the
same amount of work and we don't want
the hard jobs and our jobs aren't as
needed yeah that's true I was actually
speaking to a girl today and she was
like oh I could do an office job but I
don't want to deal with all the
paperwork yeah
men will yeah no seriously like even me
as soon as I I don't know how to work
any of that equipment I don't know how
to do anything over there and what's
easier sitting and talking on a
microwave working the equipment you know
yeah I mean you can learn I don't want
to that's why that's why King's here
and before that blessing like and even
even
um and that's the thing like a lot of
times women we don't realize we're in
the jobs we're at because we can
monetize Beauty yeah and it's not to say
we're not talented I'm sure you're a
really good dancer too but we
've been
just like men I think they're just built
for doing hard more than us agreed
and also I feel like whenever I have
like a man right and like we're talking
okay oh like this is broken can you come
fix it and he'll fix it yeah I'm also I
can't do that myself and that's and the
crazy thing is like we live in a world
where women we can actually like
almost have a husband without because
before like before you know you were
only getting that type of help from your
husband yeah but so it sort of allows us
to like live in the world because a man
will come fix something a man will come
help you yeah and you know I'm not
complaining you can do it for me but but
it kind of shows like partially why
Society is the way it is it does saying
it would depend on how it was eradicated
and how the how how The Disappearance of
it was measured and you're saying the
cost of men that's a problem Oh there's
all sorts of things that it could be at
the cost of it could even be at the cost
of women's own interests so because they
might not be happy if they get equal pay
no because it might interfere with other
things that are causing the pay Gap that
women are choosing to do like having
children well or choosing careers that
actually happen to be paid less which
women do a lot of but why shouldn't
women have the right to choose not to
have children or the right to choose
those demanding they do they can yeah
that's fine but you're saying that makes
them unhappy by and large I'm I'm saying
that that no I'm not saying that I'm I
and I actually haven't said that so far
you're saying it makes them miserable no
I said what was making them miserable
was having part was having weak partners
that makes them miserable right
um I would say that many women around
the age of I would say between 28 and 32
have a career family crisis that they
have to deal with and I think that's
partly because of the foreshortened time
frame that women have to contend with
like women have to get the major pieces
of their life put together faster than
men which is also partly why men aren't
under so much pressure to grow up so
because for the typical woman
um she has to have her career and family
in order pretty much by the time she's
35 because otherwise the options start
to run out and so that puts a tremendous
amount of stress on women especially at
the end of their 20s I think I take
issue with the idea of the typical woman
because you know all women are different
and that's why I want to just put
another quote to you from the book
different in some ways and the same in
others okay you say women become more
vulnerable when they have children and
you talk to one of your YouTube
interviews about crazy Harpy sisters so
simple question is gender equality a
myth in your view is that something
that's just never going to happen it
depends on what you mean by equality
getting the same opportunities fairly
people we could get to a point where
people were treated fairly or more
fairly I mean people are treated pretty
fairly in Western culture already but we
can they're really not though are they I
mean otherwise why would there only be
seven women running ftse 100 companies
in the UK why why would there still be a
pay gap which we've discussed why are
women at the BBC saying that they're
getting paid illegally less than men to
do the same job that's not fair that's
good at the first question they're both
complicated questions seven seven women
repeat that one there's seven women
running the top ftse 100 companies in
the UK that question might be
um why would you want to do that why
would a man want to do it
there's a certain number of of men
although not that men any who are
perfectly willing to sacrifice virtually
all of their life to the pursuit of a
high-end career so they'll work these
are men that are very intelligent
they're usually very very conscientious
they're very driven they're very high
energy they're very healthy and they're
willing to work 70 or 80 hours a week
non-stop specialized at one thing to get
to the top so you always say women are
just more sensible they don't want that
because it's not an Iceland I'm saying
that's part of it definitely and so I
work you don't think there are barriers
in their way that prevent them getting
to the top there are some barriers yeah
like other like men for example I mean
to get to the top of any organization is
an incredibly competitive Enterprise and
the men that you're competing with are
simply not going to roll over and say
please take the position so let me come
back absolutely all-out Warfare is so my
dad had a had a um company my dad and my
mom together but my dad was the the CEO
had a company with 200 people in it and
growing up my dad worked crazy hour
hours like he would work 80 hours a week
he would drive to the office at like
middle of the night to go um he had
programmers in India and he would go
like talk to them in India and there
were points where like my dad was gone
for like two weeks at a time to go to
India like he just worked really really
hard but so a lot of times when I hear
women talking about these like and this
was 200 people yeah like they're talking
about companies with hundreds yeah of
thousands like thousands of people yeah
I cannot even imagine the level of
stress that would come with so a lot of
times when they talk about women not
want it like not in these positions of
power yeah I think well I wouldn't want
to do that either I wouldn't want the
stress horrible yeah I I get stressed
out with like I don't know the I don't
know 10 people that work here right like
that stresses me out and I'm like
hundreds it's just trying to deal with
every person and managing like what
they're doing yeah project making sure
they're working it's like and it's not
even about wanting the stress or not
it's more about can you actually yeah so
you could want it but can you do it
correct that's correct and like and so a
lot of times when I hear it
because one I don't think women if they
actually had a job like that would want
to do it yeah because that wasn't yeah
yeah and I think that's and I don't
think
like feminists will think that's like an
insult but it's not meant to be insulted
like I think women we value work-life
balance yeah I I'm a hard worker and I
used to I mean I still work seven days a
week but I choose now to have one day
off yeah so I can just do my own things
and have a work-life balance and we tend
to pick jobs that are more fun yeah yeah
like these are we were like we both have
fun jobs you know but but you see what
I'm saying so it's like a lot of times
they think it's like this malicious men
are out to get us when it's mourna we
don't our choice at the end of the day
yeah gender equality a myth I don't know
what you mean by the question men and
women aren't the same and they won't be
the same that doesn't mean they can't be
treated fairly is gender equality
desirable if it means equality of
outcome then almost certainly it's
undesirable that's already been
demonstrated in Scandinavia because in
scandinia what do you mean by the
equality of outcome is undesirable well
men and women won't sort themselves into
the same categories if you leave them
alone to do it off their own accord I've
already seen that in Scandinavia it's 20
so female nurses to male something like
that it might not be quite that extreme
and approximately the same male
Engineers to female engineers and that's
a consequence of the free choice of men
and women in the societies that have
gone farther than any other societies to
make gender equality the purpose of the
law those are inerradicable differences
you can eradicate them with tremendous
social pressure and tyranny but if you
leave men and women to make their own
choices you will not get equal outcomes
right so you're saying that anyone who
believes in equality whether you call
them feminist coolant whatever you want
to call them should basically give up
because it ain't gonna happen only if
they're aiming at equality of outcome so
you're saying give people equality of
opportunity that's fine not only fine
it's eminently desirable for everyone
for individuals and for society but
still women aren't going to make it
that's what you're really saying it
depends on your measurement techniques
they're doing just fine in medicine in
fact there are far more female
Physicians than there are male
Physicians there are lots of lots of
disciplines that are absolutely
dominated by women many many disciplines
and they're doing great so let me put
something else to you from the book you
say the introduction of the you know
they never talk about either how models
are paid more if you're a woman really
yeah what do you mean really I didn't
know that any any industry where you can
monetize your face basically women out
earn men any any industry that's super
hard and requires a lot of discipline
men men even medicine if you look at
like the top because there are more
female Physicians but they tend to do
like um like uh like being like general
physicians if you look at like the top
like brain surgeons men dominate wow
yeah well it's not a bad thing right men
would do the same thing if they could
yeah if guys could and they do right
they do but like social media when they
can the reality of men could monetize
only fans men would dominate only fans
as well yeah yeah it's just cause we
can't yeah no but I know quite a few
male people right that do that yeah but
that's an exception and uh yeah but
that's an exception how and it's an
exception because they're a very small
number it's not General man because most
men can't make money on only fans and if
you were to look at the actual numbers
the highest and only fans is not going
to be a man it's not even going to be
close if you look at them top 10 I can
guarantee that top 10 is not even a man
is not going to be in top ten but I'd
say on Tick Tock opposite men dominate
well that's because Tick Tock you can
you can make a lot of you can generate
views from educational content as well I
would actually say that tick tock women
get followings quicker
blow up so you'll see girls blow up from
just like mouthing lyrics yeah but when
men blow up they're typically are doing
something give them value yeah yeah
where the women and I'll I'll give you
an example
um actually no
I was thinking I was like tick tock's
just a different animal I was gonna say
copy or whatever but I was like he's
just stands there too you know what I'm
talking about no the the most followed
tick-tocker is something yeah yeah yeah
it's like you just really do
no he's funny though right yeah that's
the point it's comedy right yeah yeah
compared to Charlie demilio correct I
mean she is a Dancer she is a dancer and
she's got pretty face so you can see why
yeah it's more of like a beauty thing
yeah where where men it's like comedy I
will say tick tock isn't the best
example because Tick Tock it's short
form content so when I actually think
women tend to dominate in short form and
men tend to dominate in long form
interesting and even the way we speak
like women we go on these random
tangents we don't get everything we do
we do
like fraction with a man and a woman
always like I did the same reaction with
a dude yeah it's like half the time yeah
I know I know
the funny dance funny thing but not not
in a bad way but just when it comes to
content creation like Mr Beast versus
the the top female YouTuber is like uh
one of them I know is David dobrik's
girlfriend who is
yeah yeah that's just I know there's
bigger ones than her yeah but what's the
value like Mr Beast is like curing kids
from being blind and she's doing some
dances you
yeah and and you know I could even to
myself there's another guy that has a
similar show to me he was like a federal
agent yeah he's like hey do you know
Myron fresh and fit no they have a
similar show to mine okay and same with
another one's called whatever now
whatever podcast was a guy that did
prank videos he's been on YouTube for
like 10 years okay
um Myron's a guy who um was a federal
agent for like 10 years and me I just
woke up and did YouTube it's like
I just woke up and then I think I'm
gonna start this podcast we really and
it's not to say I I don't do a good job
but you do a brilliant job thank you
thank you I do I do and I'm really proud
of it but to to act like I had no
Advantage because I'm a woman yeah he's
silly you know and I think we can
acknowledge these advantages without dis
because a lot of times people think I'm
like discrediting myself it's not
discrediting I do a great job but life
is easier when you're a chick it just is
it is a work argument it immediately
complicates even salary comparison
Beyond practicality for one simple
reason who decides what work is equal
it's not possible so the simple question
is do you believe in equal pay well I
made the argument there it's like it
depends
not saying that at all at all because a
lot of people
will just say I mean
they're actually not listening
you think she's listening carefully no
definitely not I'm never going to make
it on equal terms equal outcomes is what
how you define it no idea
I would go well I might as well just go
and play with my Cindy dolls trying at
school because I'm not going to get the
top job I want because someone's sitting
there saying it's not possible
desirable that's what I said it's a it's
a bad social support I didn't say that
women shouldn't be striving for the top
or anything like that because I don't
believe that for a second striving for
the top but you're going to put all
those hurdles in their way as has been
in their way for centuries and that's
fine you're saying that's fine no no I
think I really the patriarchal system is
just that's silly I do I think that's
silly I really do I mean look look at
your situation you're hardly
unsuccessful yeah
exactly good that's okay battling is
good this is all about inevitable but
you talk about men fighting let me just
put on
well I notice in your book you talk
about real conversation I guess you just
ignores that she just ignored him of
course it's going to be going to be hard
like you seem to put in the hours
regardless putting the hours in the
hardware he'll get there you're kind of
switching now you don't like her yeah
it's between men containing quote an
underlying threat of physicality oh
there's no doubt about that what about
real conversations between women is that
something or are we sort of too amenable
and reasonable no it's just that the
domain of physical conflict is sort of
off limits for you
to get where I've got yeah but what does
that means I don't imagine that you've
yeah to some degree I suspect you're not
very agreeable so that's the thing
successful women I'm not very agreeable
right I don't know that actually in this
conversation at least and I'm sure it
served your career well successful women
though basically have to wear the
trousers in your view they have to sort
of become men to succeed is what you're
saying well I've had to fight to succeed
against man certainly masculine traits
are going to be helpful I mean one of
the things I do in in my Counseling
Practice this for example when I'm
Consulting with women who are trying to
advance their careers is to teach them
how to negotiate and to and to be able
to say no and to not be easily pushed
around and to be formidable and you need
to if you're going to be successful you
need to be smart conscientious and tough
well here's a radical idea why don't the
bosses adopt some the male bosses shall
we say adopt some female trades so that
women don't have to fight and get their
sharp elbows out for the pay Rises it's
just accepted if they're doing the same
job they get the same pay well I would
say partly because it's not so easy to
determine what constitutes the same job
because arguably yeah there are still
men dominating our Industries our
society and therefore they've dictated
the terms for so long that women have to
battle to not like them it's not true
it's not true so for example well I can
give you an example very quickly so I
worked with women who worked in
high-powered law firms in Canada for
about 15 years and they were as
competent and put together as anybody
you would ever meet and we were trying
to figure out how to further their
careers and there was a huge debate in
Canadian Society at that point that was
basically ran along the same lines as
your argument as the law firms didn't
use these masculine criteria then
perhaps women would do better but the
market sets the damn game it's like and
the market is dominated by men it's not
the market is dominated by women they
make 80 of the consumer decisions that's
not the case
people who stay at home looking after
does that surprise you
yes that woman make 80 percent of
consumer buying decisions yeah so our
entire Society is catered to women it's
not catered to men why all of the
politicians they Pander to women all of
the CEOs they have to please women
everything is towards women and once you
see it it's like you cannot say I'll
give you an example so how do
politicians get elected they get voted
didn't they correct Now who is the
single biggest voter block that's a name
single women single mothers so when
they're speaking politicians realize
this and they know they they cannot talk
about certain topic topics or pass
certain laws if women are because
otherwise they won't get reelected it's
the same thing with the media why do you
think they have fat chicks on the covers
of magazines now do you think men like
that I no no she's from Australia I
actually had a girl from my team on
Australia yeah and she she was like your
size actually yeah but she would always
talk about how fat she was like that's
that's the crazy which you you're
reasonable you know but she was always
like running and stuff because she said
in Australia the body standards are like
way higher like like they would not get
away yeah yeah yeah they are yeah and
like obviously girls walk around the
beach and I'm like oh I need to lose
this much I need to like coming here I
was 10 kilos heavier and I have lost 10
Killers so you know I have lost weight
that I wanted to lose but then I look at
myself I'm like I still could lose and
turn up a little bit right but but you
understand because you're from Australia
like that the fat chicks isn't what they
want yeah but but the thing is
um that's like that's why all the
marketing like is catered to women and
the wet men tell us what they want to
hear too what we want to hear too
because they don't get laid unless they
tell us what we want to hear so a lot of
times we'll go through our whole lives
yeah never having heard What Men really
think that's just so annoying I'm like
just be honest up front the problem is
we don't like it when they're honest I
would rather the person even if it hurt
me you you might you might okay okay if
a guy cheated on you and he told you
would you stay no see this is like I
said they won't be honest
no it's happened to me and did you stay
or no no he so he didn't tell me first I
found it well I knew basically you had a
feeling and then you went through his
phone well no basically it was in my
house
um it were in camera how did you find
out I was half asleep oh he did it with
you there yeah I was there
um so wow I woke up like nothing had
happened then I'd hurt myself on the
Wednesday it's like this was the weekend
before
and then he comes over after
um you kneel something with his brother
and I can't say anything obviously
because I wasn't that person
so I just messaged him ago call me and I
was like we need to talk about the
relationship he just wouldn't call me
he was only texting me and told me I was
like oh like be honest with me did you
do anything with her while we were
together denied it she denied it three
times and then finally I was like tell
me now and he told you and he was like
yeah Didn't They that's why I was so
quiet did you ever did you ever see him
again after that no never I sent him a
big long-ass message saying don't talk
to me ever again okay wow and you never
even had a conversation with him again
maybe once on social media saying hi
like UK or hateful he in the shade of it
okay and then so you responded a little
bit but then you I said see you later
see you later don't talk to me you're in
the minority usually girls will just
keep them around forever not me not you
if you piss me off see you later and by
and large they are still women so
they're going out doing the shopping but
that has changed
decisions okay so what a market is
driven by women not men right okay and
if you're a lawyer they still pay more
for the same sort of goods that's been
proven that men for the you buy a blue
bicycle helmet it's gonna cost less than
a pink one anyway we'll come on to that
partly because men are less agreeable
right so so they won't put up with it I
want to ask you is it not desirable to
have some of those female traits you're
talking about I'd say that's a
generalization but you've used the words
female traits is it not desirable to
have some of them at the top of business
I mean maybe they wouldn't have been
they don't predicting the banking crisis
they don't predict success in the
workplace the things that predict
success in the workplace are
intelligence and conscientiousness
agreeableness negatively predicts
success in the workplace High negative
emotions you're saying that women aren't
intelligent enough to run these top
countries no I didn't say that at all
that female traits don't predict success
but I didn't say that intelligence
wasn't I didn't say that intelligence
and conscientiousness
by implication are not female traits oh
no I mean that's certainly not saying
that at all are women less intelligent
than men no a lot no they're not no the
the data on that's pretty clear the
average IQ for a woman and the average
IQ for a man is identical there is some
debate about the flatness of the
distribution which is something that
James demore pointed out for example
this memo but there's no difference at
all in general cognitive ability there's
no difference to speak of in
conscientiousness women are a bit more
orderly than men and men are a little
bit more industrious than women but the
difference isn't big but that averages
into content can you imagine you aren't
necessarily well of course
so why are they not feminine traits why
are they not desirable at the top of
feminine traits why are they not
desirable at the top it's hard to say
I'm just laying out the empirical
evidence like we know that we know the
traits that predict success but we also
know because companies by and large have
not been dominated by women over the
centuries we have nothing to compare it
to it's an experiment true and it could
be the case that if companies modified
their behavior and became more feminine
they would be successful but there's no
evidence for it I'm not neither doubtful
nor non-doubtful there's no evidence why
not give it a go as the radical because
the evidence suggests well it's fine if
like if someone wants to start a company
and make it more feminine and
compassionate let's say and caring in
its overall orientation towards its
workers and towards the marketplace then
that's a perfectly reasonable experiment
to run my point is that there is no
evidence that those traits predict
success in the workplace and there's
everything being tried well that's not
that's not really the case women have
been in the workplace for what at least
ever since I've been around the
representation of women in the workplace
has been about 50 so we've run the
experiment for a fair fairly reasonable
period of time but not you know
certainly not for centuries let me move
on to another debate that's been very
controversial for you and this is you
got in trouble for refusing to call
Trans men and women by their preferred
personal pronouns
it's not actually true I got in trouble
because I said I would not follow the
compelled speech dictates of the federal
and provincial government I actually
never got in trouble for not calling
anyone anything right she keeps trying
to put words in his mouth I know yeah
they do that to me too they'll be like
you hate women no and then I'll be like
when did I say that well you said that
it's never it's never
hahaha yeah I wouldn't follow that but
this is what feminist ideology does to
you in the long run like does she look
like a happy woman no like I can like
see like anger coming out of her eyes
like you can you can tell a lot by the
pet by their eyes yeah she just looks
angry law which was designed it was lost
no no no they said it was designed to do
okay you cited freedom of speech in that
why should your right to freedom of
speech Trump a trans person's right not
to be offended because in order to be
able do you think that we should have
laws that say we have to call Trans
people by their pronouns should we let
them in our bathrooms it's a hard one to
say ah oh it is a hard one to say no it
is because I know
I know that you know can you call me
Your Majesty please from now on I'd like
I'd like it legally required
that's that's a bit weird but why is it
not weird why is it not weird when they
want to pretend to be something they're
not because it's weird because I'm not
I'm not royalty right yeah but it'd be
like I think it'd be weird if I said you
have to call me he when I'm clearly not
a he I feel like this is this is very
controversial obviously yeah obviously
because I know people that have gone
down that road so it's hard because they
they personally feel like they are like
a she or a he even though they're not
born like that I am a queen I wasn't
born a queen but you're a queen but I am
now I am now royalty and I now need
everybody to bow when I come in and call
me queen in your magic can you can you
King please take notes everybody just
take notes please
he would have a better case his name's
King you know yeah
he would yeah but it's like like I don't
think it would be kind for you guys to
go with that like I think you would be
then letting me be delusional like don't
you think we're kind of letting them be
delusional like would you want to date
uh a she he like a she that became a he
no no yeah right right and I also
remember the first time that I did go
into
a gay club it was like last year
beginning of the year or start this year
pretty sure it was last year and I went
in and I went into the bathroom and it
was weird for me personally only because
obviously I haven't been brought up that
way and everyone's different
um to see a trans guy who's now a girl
go into the same bathroom as me
personally I felt a bit
thank you thank you because that's it
yeah no and it's uncomfortable and it's
like okay and we all know that in the
bathrooms we become best friends yes yes
like men just don't understand nothing
goes on in the girls bathroom nice like
oh can you come to the bathroom with me
and they're like why are you going to
the bathroom together what are you doing
it's an experience it is I've got so
many friends in there it's like it's
like the same way the boys go on their
boys trip yeah and it's an experience
it's just not the same when the women
tag along it's the same thing with our
bathroom it is it is I do agree we
couldn't do a whole trip women will kill
each other yeah girls trips they always
come back half hating each other however
me and my best friend now we went on
holiday six weeks after knowing each
other and now we live together moved in
together after three months of knowing
each other oh wow there's exceptions
right it happens right I actually I
think female friendships are better
one-on-one when it becomes like four and
five oh that's when they go no that's
yeah yeah but like I think female
friendships are so much better one it's
like one-on-one because when it's like
four and five that's when all the cat
like that's why sales happens sorority
houses yeah that's an American thing you
guys don't I understand you it's fine
because movies but yeah I think you have
to risk being offensive I mean look at
the conversation we're having right now
you know like you're certainly willing
to risk offending me in the pursuit of
Truth why should you have the right to
do that it's been rather uncomfortable
well I'm I'm very glad I put you on the
spot well I'm great
you get my point it's like you're you're
doing what you should do which is
digging a bit to see what the hell is
going on and that is what you should do
but you're exercising your freedom of
speech to certainly risk offending me
and that's fine I think more power too
as far as I'm concerned so you haven't
sat there and I'm just right I've just
tried to work that out I mean ha gotcha
you have got me you have got me I'm
trying to work that through my head yeah
yeah it took a while it took a while it
did yeah it took a while this was like
internet history this is this is
internet gold where's she now do I think
she still works there maybe I don't know
and you can tell it's not it's certainly
not married but it was so bad that she
said
um you certainly got me even if you like
that wasn't professional on her part to
admit yeah
yeah she'll forever be known as that
chick that he schooled woman freak you
have voluntarily come into the studio
and agreed to be questioned a trans
person in your class has come to your
class and said they want to be called
that's never happened
and I would call them she so you would
so you've kind of changed your tune no
no I said that right from the beginning
what I said at the beginning was that I
was not going to seed the linguistic
territory to radical leftists regardless
of whether or not it was put in law
that's what I said and then the people
who came after me said well you must be
transphobic and you mistreat a student
in your class it's like I never
mistreated a student in my class I'm not
transphobic and that isn't what I said
well except you've also called trans
campaigners authoritarian how many I
mean isn't that well only in the broader
context of my claims that radical
leftist ideologues are authoritarians
which they are saying someone who's
trying to work out their gender identity
who may well have struggled with that
had quite a bit of time you're comparing
them with you know Chairman Mao who no
just saw the deaths of millions of
people even if the activists you know
they're trans people too they have a
right to say these things yeah but they
don't have the right right their whole
Community to Chairman Mao you know I
could
you know this is grossly insensitive I
didn't compare them to finish it well I
did compare them he wasn't authoritarian
he's a rape Winger though I was
comparing them to the left-wing
totalitarians and I do believe they are
left totalitarians on The Mao millions
of people died right I mean there's no
comparison between Mao and a trans
activist is there why not
because trans activists aren't killing
millions of people
the philosophy that's guiding their
utterances is the same philosophy the
consequences are yet
you're saying that trans activists could
lead to the deaths of millions of people
no I'm saying that the philosophy that
drives their utterances is the same
philosophy that already has driven us to
the deaths of millions okay tell us how
that philosophy
is in any way comparable
sure that's no problem the first thing
is is that the philosophy presumes that
group identity is Paramount that's the
fundamental philosophy that drove the
Soviet Union and maoist China and it's
the fundamental philosophy of the
left-wing activists its identity
politics doesn't matter who you are as
an individual it matters who you are do
you think that's common like people
talking about their identity rather than
like issues yes yeah do you see that
what's the most common thing you hear
it's more like you need to call them by
she her like what's your what are your
pronouns that's the first thing that
comes out yeah it's on every document
now as well who do you go by she has and
it's so crazy because it's such a small
percentage of people yeah that are
making everybody it's it's I think it's
narcissistic like imagine if I said okay
I am a ginger and now I want everybody
to talk about their hair color because
I'm only one percent I'm the most rare
hair color
um Everybody Needs you need to come in
and acknowledge your hair that would be
crazy right you would look at me like a
crazy person but for some reason it's
like less than two percent of the
population gets to dictate the way we
all live yeah it's not right really yeah
in terms of your group identity you just
is it worse is that stuff is the trans
stuff worse or better in Australia I'd
say it's better better it's not as bad
yeah it's 10 times worse here yeah it's
so in America yeah
right that you hate to be compared to
you want to stir things up I'm only a
provocateur insofar as when I say what I
believe to be true it's provocative I
don't provoke maybe for you don't set
out now and then I'm not interested in
provoking but what about thinking about
you know fighting and the lobster tell
us about the lobster
well that's quite a segue well the first
chapter I have in my book is called
stand up straight with your shoulders
back and it's an injunction to be
combative not least to further your
career let's say but also to adopt a
stance of ready engagement with the
world and to reflect that in your
posture and the reason that I write
about lobsters is because there's this
idea that hierarchical structures are a
sociological construct of the western
patriarchy and that is so untrue that
it's almost unbelievable and I use the
lobster as an example because the
lobster we we divulge from lobsters in
evolutionary history about 350 million
years ago common ancestor and lobsters
exist in hierarchies and they have a
nervous system attuned to the hierarchy
and that nervous system runs on
serotonin just like our nervous systems
do and the nervous system of the lobster
and of the human being is so similar
that antidepressants work on lobsters
and it's part of my attempt to
demonstrate that the idea of hierarchy
has absolutely nothing to do with
socio-cultural construction which it
doesn't let me just get this straight
you're saying that we should organize
our societies along the lines of the
lobsters I'm saying that it's inevitable
that there will be continuity in the way
that animals and human beings organize
organize their structures it's it's
absolutely inevitable and there is one
third of a billion years of evolutionary
history behind that right that's that's
so long that a third of a billion years
ago there weren't even trees it's a long
time you have a mechanism in your brain
that runs on serotonin that's similar to
The Lobster mechanism that tracks your
status and the higher your status the
better your emotions are regulated so as
your serotonin levels increase you feel
more positive emotion and less negative
emotion so you're saying like the
lobsters it's actually so interesting
it has men and women to do certain
things to sort of run a long-term lines
and there's nothing we can do about it
no I'm not saying there's nothing we can
do about it because it's like a in a
chess game right there's lots of things
that you can do although you can't break
the rules of the chess game and continue
to play chess biological your biological
nature is somewhat like that is it sets
the rules of the game but within those
rules you have a lot of leeway but the
idea that but one thing we can't do is
say that hierarchical organization is a
consequence of the capitalist patriarchy
it's like that's patently absurd it's
wrong it's not a matter of opinion it's
seriously wrong
aren't you just whipping people up into
a state of anger and not at all
divisions between men and women you'd
stirring people up you know you have any
critics of you online get absolutely
lambasted by your followers
generally sorry your critics get
lambasted by you I mean if they're
actually responsible not at all if an
academic is going to come after me and
tell me that I'm not qualified and that
I'm not I don't know what I'm talking
about
followers now quit the abuse quit the
anger Well we'd need some substantial
examples of the abuse and the anger
before I could detail that question
there's a lot of it out there for well
let's take a more General perspective on
that so I have had 25
000 letters since June something like
that from people who told me that I've
brought them back from the brink of
Destruction and so I'm perfectly willing
to put that up against the rather vague
accusations that my followers are making
the lives of people that I've targeted
miserable Jordan Peterson thank you my
pleasure nice talking with you so what
what was your Jordan Peterson experience
what did you think so this is the
experience of someone their first Jordan
Peterson video ever it's hard because I
I see his point of view but then I see
her point of view okay you still see you
would say you see both points yeah what
what do you what do you not see like
what just give me your general thoughts
you could you could in what way what
thoughts what did you think about the
topics they were talking about the pay
Gap hierarchy the pay obviously depends
on the hours obviously that the men the
women put in and I know obviously if I'm
watching that that women obviously don't
want to put in as much work as men
um so what did you agree with that Kathy
said
now think about it I don't know
well uh did you like Jordan did
you think he was smart would you watch
him again yeah I would watch him again
actually yeah yeah he was a smart guy he
is he's got knowledge yeah
um well any other final thoughts you got
on the video no my final thoughts but at
all no well thank you for coming in
thank you for having me well red pill
you further in the future uh King any
final thoughts you got nah nah all right
guys all right guys like the video on
your way out um subscribe to the channel
and let me know what do you want me to
see her get red pilled in next where can
they find you you know put your
Instagram or anything you can find me on
Instagram it's Sophia with ph Kate we're
the next Eon Kate um and my Tick Tock is
these okay perfect guys like the video
on your way out subscribe to the channel
and I'll talk to you next time